excédé par le trafic de drogue des
habitants d'un quartier de Marseille ont
récemment décidé de prendre une décision
radicale les habitants d'un immeuble ont
trouvé le courage de s'opposer aux
dealers depuis plusieurs jours ses
habitants se relaient jour et nuit au
pied de leur immeuble pour monter la
garde le but empêcher des trafiquants de
drogue de revenir s'installer dans leur
quartier nous on veut vraiment plus
qu'il soit dans la cités peuvent aller
vendre si faire ce qu'ils veulent mais
plus chez nous les résidents déterminés
qui n'hésitent pas à manifester pour se
faire entendre et qui ont déjà réussi à
les faire fuir grâce à leur tour de gars
toute la place ils peuvent pas venir sur
nos genoux hein on ne lâchera rien on se
tient les coudes si leur déloger à
Marseille la police doit-elle être
présente à l'entrée des immeubles de
quartiers sensibles
merci d'être là merci Océane et merci
Sofia d'être là alors c'est incroyable
parce que c'est vrai qu'on se dit
comment est venu l'idée déjà comment ça
s'est passé ben en fait moi j'étais venu
pour voir mon père parce que moi je suis
plus une locataire d'ici j'ai grandi au
campanule je suis né et mon père il
habite toujours et en fait je suis venu
le voir pour le souhaiter la bonne année
et en fait en bas j'ai vu 15 personnes
qui avaient reçu les lieux sur des
tables sur des chaises avec des canapés
et qui bloquait l'entrée masquer jusqu'à
là
lunettes capuchée et en fait ils avaient
essayé de prendre possession du logement
de l'immeuble de la tour h d'accord dans
laquelle moi et Sofia en vie qui est ma
voisine et donc du coup moi je suis
montée pour avertir mon père j'ai des
gens bizarres bah je crois qu'il y a un
réseau qui est en train de s'installer
tellement que on s'y attendait pas et il
m'a dit que tu me racontes il m'a dit
c'est pas possible et de là je lui ai
dit oui oui je crois qu'il y a un réseau
qui en train de s'installer et le
lendemain du coup c'était vraiment la
stricte vérité de 15 ils ont pas ça 40
ils ont investi tout le long tout le
ils ont commencé par les petits
battements les bâtiments B donc après
les voisins ils ont décidé de les
déloger après ils ont investi la tour g
la que vous voyez en photo et nous en
fait on est la plus grande tour la tour
voyant en photo c'est la hache c'est là
où nous vivons c'est la nôtre c'est la
nôtre voilà c'est celle qu'on a investit
depuis maintenant 11 jours on a décidé
de poser
et ils vendaient de leur drogue ah ouais
tranquille voilà tranquillement ils ont
bloqué l'accès à aux personnes âgées
donc les personnes âgées les forces de
l'ordre les forces de l'ordre ils ont eu
je crois des milliers d'appels sans être
marseillaise ils ont eu vraiment des
milliers d'appels
ils étaient là le problème c'est que
malheureusement quand ils viennent ils
ont rien sur eux donc ils les arrêtent
il les relâchent deux heures après c'est
ça et ils reviennent direct nous on a
des donc Socha est descendu en bas elle
est partie devrait un sandwich et une
canette et moi je l'ai j'ai suivi
qu'est-ce que je faisais là
je suis venu vous tenir compagnie
d'accord parce que c'est mon bâtiment et
vous n'êtes pas d'ici c'est pas nos
enfants c'est même pas nous les enfants
de nos quartiers c'est des enfants qui
viennent d'ailleurs et des quartiers
plus loin
alors sachez que Marseille Nord
Marseille sud-est Marseille sud-ouest
c'est vrai qu'on entend Marseille
il fait bon vivre chez nous au sud-est
il n'y a pas de problème
Marseille sud-est il n'y a jamais eu
tout ce que vous entendez il fait bon
vivre chez nous donc voilà donc on a une
grande résidence avec plusieurs accès de
rentrée sortie
là on a fait en sorte avec des sachez
aussi il y a pas longtemps nous avons eu
quand même des millions d'euros de
réhabilitation d'accord c'est une
résidence qui a été réhabilitée de la
tête aux pieds intérieur extérieur et là
malheureusement notre bâtiment on l'a
pas reconnu et donc et donc là
aujourd'hui vous en êtes où mais alors
aujourd'hui ça fait 11 jours du coup
qu'on est en bas donc on a décidé de
médiatiser l'affaire parce qu'on sait
que quand on y met les médias
ça avance nous on avait évoqué à Erilia
du coup des revendications on a une
pétition avec plus de 300 signatures
donc on les a mis en demeure pour la
protection et la sécurité des locaux
parce que on a des rien d'autre à faire
il fallait qu'en fait chaque bâtiment et
plus de 50% de de signatures pour la
pétition et après on n'a pas fait
vraiment du porte-à-porte mais on a
quand même réussi à réunir plus de 300
signatures sur vos 500 logements et on
en est fier parce que on a réussi à
faire du coup de manifestation qui a
rassemblé pratiquement aujourd'hui c'est
vous en avez ils sont où ces personnes
ils sont dans le quartier elle est
déloger des bâtiments mais
malheureusement
à l'extérieur et ils ont décidé de faire
un drive ah ouais donc
nous on a empêché les acheteurs de
mais malheureusement
ça va vite on les voit ça va vite ça va
en trottinette ça s'arrête nous on veut
que ça s'arrête
la police mais la police ils sont
vraiment très présent c'est ce qu'on a
pas retrouvé
[Musique]
on sait très bien que la drogue du coup
bah il y a des armes derrière et qu'on
peut avoir des revendications des
représailles pardon mais après
honnêtement ont peur pour avoir peur on
préfère avoir peur maintenant que
d'avoir peur dans dans 6 mois si nous
envahi la cité et qu'on peut plus sortir
donc on préfère avoir peur maintenant
pour sauver nos familles et pour sauver
les personnes âgées pour sauver cette
résidence qui est vraiment propre qui
est belle qui est calme surtout qui est
vraiment calme on n'a jamais eu de on
n'a jamais eu de drogue dans cette dans
cette résidence franchement c'est
c'est c'est décevant parce que on est on
est vraiment fatigué ça fait 11 jours
qu'on lutte
12h3h du matin de midi à 3h du matin on
est en bas on a on a réussi à faire un
collectif tous ensemble tout l'immeuble
de la tour h et tous les autres
locataires aussi de des autres tu m'as
bien d'autres bâtiment mais
malheureusement dans leur bâtiment voilà
il y a des personnes un peu plus
fragiles que donc du coup ils
peuvent pas investir leur bâtiment comme
nous on a fait bravo à vous deux en tout
cas bravo à vous vous voulez
bravo
[Applaudissements]
c'est une résonance
ce que ça a pas été mis en avant on
remercie aussi la préfète on a eu la
préfète qui est venue nous rendre visite
ça Medja elle est venu de elle-même
voilà nous a expliqué qu'elle allait
mettre tout en oeuvre là en ce moment on
a eu des revendications on a mis notre
bailleur sociaux lundi on le revoit pour
du coup on va écouter les doléances des
locataires et là du coup on a une équipe
de huit vigiles qui sont assez remontées
donc qui doit être sur 7 et on va
essayer de d'abord d'autres trucs
merci d'avoir été la bienvenue
j'ai un petit message à passer oui à
toute la France nous avons une
génération qui la jeune génération parce
que c'est des enfants de 8 à 14 ans que
nous avons ce n'est pas des adultes
c'est ça c'est important des adultes
donc maintenant c'est plus haut faut
changer aussi les lois des mineurs il y
a beaucoup de choses on en parle
beaucoup de ça ici il y a beaucoup de
choses on sort des lois parce qu'on a
donné une petite fessée à un enfant bien
sûr alors comme elle laisse des enfants
de 8 ans avec des armes
je suis d'accord
je dors plus voilà j'ai perdu ma voix
c'est pas ma voix
qui bougent vous avez raison pour donner
la fessée aux enfants etc mais on a des
lois qui datent il y a très très
longtemps et aujourd'hui les mineurs de
2022 c'est pas les mineurs
et ce qui se passe aussi je vous le dis
c'est que c'est que en plus et puis il y
a des mecs au dessus vous voyez qui se
servent des mineurs bien sûr et donc
c'est ça qui se passe et il se servent
des mineurs pour leur faire faire toutes
les conneries et puis ils se disent de
façon
de plus en plus comme ça que ça se passe
et ça il faut que ça bouge on espère
qu'un jour
Éric Dupond-Moretti
cette discussion ce sont les parents je
pense que c'est la rééducation des
parents qui font faut rééduquer les
parents merci en tout cas merci
à vous